♪ ♪ ♪
- Dix à 13 heures de travail
par jour, 6 jours sur 7, à faire
des tâches d'entretien ménager
ou à organiser des activités
pour divertir les campeurs
pour un salaire d'un peu moins
de 4 dollars de l'heure.
Voilà la réalité décrite
par deux travailleurs mexicains
du camping Havana Resort
de Maricourt, qui ont accepté
de témoigner sous le couvert
de l'anonymat en raison de
la situation précaire liée à
leur statut juququque au pays.
- (interprète, femme):
Être exploités de cette manière,
c'étvrvrvraiment humiliant.
Ils nous payaient 300 $
par semaine.
- (interprète, homme): On était
vraiment payés très peu.- - - B.
- L'employeur leur aurait
demandé d'arriver au Canada
en tant que touristes, puis
il aurait promis qu'un permis
de travail leur serait délivré
plus tard après leur arrivée,
promesse qui n'aurait jamais
été tenue.
- (interprète, femme): Ils nous
disaient : "Si tu ne fais pas
bien ton travail, tu n'en auras
pas, de permis!"
C'était le genre de pression
qu'ils utilisaient presque
tous les jours.
- Sans un permis de travail,
il est illégal pour les
travailleurs étrangers d'occuper
un emploi au Canada.
- Pour moi, c'est carrément
de la traite humaine
qu'on a faite chez Havana Club.
- Le Réseau d'aide aux
travailleuses et travailleurs
migrants agricoles du Québec
estime que les agissements
du Camping Havana, en plus
d'être illégaux, ont maintenu
les travailleurs dans une
situation de grande précarité.
MICHEL PILON, dg Réseaux d'aide
aux travailleurs migrants ag
- Aussi, avec un permis de
tourisme, ils n'ont pas le droit
à l'assurance-emploi; ils n'ont
pas le droit au... s'ils ont un
accident de travaie e e e e sont
pas protégés; si... Ils n'ont
pas droit à l'assurance maladie.
Lorsqu'on les fait venir
avec des permis de touriste,
ça ne coûte rien. Ça ne c
rien à l'employeur, puis ça leur
permet aussi de les exploiter
encore plus en sachant très bien
qu'ils sont des illégaux.
- Cette avocate spéc
en droit de l'immigration croit
aussi que la situation peut être
décrite comme de la traite
de la personne.
Me YASMINE G, , , , , avocate
spéc., droit de l'immigration
- Quiconque qui volontairement
organise la venue d'immigrants
au Canada pour l'induire
en err     être considéré
pour du trafic de personnes.
- Le responsable du Camping
Havana Resort juge qu'il n'a
rien à se reprocher.
- Ce que moi, j'avais promis,
je l'ai très bien f
puis encore plus même.
♪ ♪ ♪
- Quant aux employés de
l'animation, Dominic Perrier
soutient qu'ilt t t t t t pas
besoin de permis de travail
puisqu'il les considère
comme des artistes et qu'aucun
salaire n'aura été versé
puisqu'i b b b b b bénévoles.
DOMINIC PERRIER, responsable,
Camping Havana Resort
- Tant que ça restait
dans le domaine artistique,
t t t t t t des gens de ça...
Nos conseillers juridiques nous
ont dit qu'il n'y avait aucun
problème, ça fait qu'il y avait
aucun problème pour faire ça,
ça fait qu'on a trouvé la faço
de... c'était notre façon à nous
de les inviter pour
les connaître puis nous faire
connaître en même temps.
- Ça prend un permis de travail.
- Trois experts en
consultés par Radio-Canada sont
catégoriques : l'exception qui
est prévue pour les artistes
ne s'applique pas aux animateurs
embauchés dans un camping
pour plusis.s.s.s.s.s.s.
Ici Thomas Deshaies,
Radio-Canada, Sherbrook